quand j'étais adolescente
une des grandes questions que je me
posais c'était pourquoi est ce que la
main de ma mère ressemble beaucoup à ma
main mais mes doigts ne ressemble pas du
tout aux doigts de ma voisine
j'ai toujours été intéressé par la
biologie mais j'ai fait des études de
physique en gardant toujours au fond de
la tête que j'aimerais bien étudié la
morphogénèse comment les organismes
créer des formes
les plantes sont spéciales pour plein de
raisons différentes déjà elle ne
nourrissent et elle crée tout notre
oxygène sans voix le pire mais on
pourrait pas vivre donc je pense que
c'est extrêmement important de les
étudier
les plantes sont vraiment des
architectes des ingénieurs extrêmement
performantes elles sont capables en même
temps d'être suffisamment molle et
flexible pour grandir très très
rapidement tout en étant suffisamment
rigide pour supporter des poids qui sont
très importants je vois les plantes un
petit peu comme un pont à suspension
dans un pont par exemple on peut trouver
certaines structures qui vont être sous
tension et d'autres sous pression et
c'est ce jeu et de tensions et de
compression qui vont faire que le pont
est stable je pense que les plantes
utilisent ce genre de principe pour
augmenter leur stabilité
étudier les plantes et comprendre les
plantes ça nous donne des pistes pour
comprendre des êtres vivants qui sont
très différentes nous qui sont tout le
temps avec nous un mais qui qui sont
profondément différents dans leur
biologie et je pense que si on arrive à
comprendre et les plantes et avoir un
petit peu d'empathie pour les plantes
on pourra peut-être avoir un petit peu
plus de compréhension et d'empathie
si par exemple on arrive à contacter un
jour des extraterrestres si le ministère
de l'éducation devait me demander qu'est
ce qu'on doit introduire alec à l'école
je dirais le jardinage parce que ça
permet vraiment de comprendre intimement
les plantes de comprendre leurs besoins
et de comprendre leur intelligence d'une
certaine façon comment elle
elle arrive à s'adapter à différentes
conditions là la pelouse me rend triste
[Rires]
[Musique]